if you don't mind taking a moment and
sharing with everybody your story that'd
be great to just get started with that
oh yeah i'm i don't know how far back i
should start but go from eighth grade go
from when you were in school
and you know some decisions you made and
what you did go go back yeah so um
in eighth grade i was
getting in a lot of trouble
um running with with the wrong crowd of
people i uh ended up going to juvenile
detention for a while
when i got out i
started ninth grade and stopped so i
never graduated ninth grade
and um
was just kind of running around
aimlessly without a goal without
something to work work towards and and
growing up i always loved combat sports
and uh at what age like how soon was it
as far back as i can remember oh really
yeah i remember uh getting excited going
to friend's house for mike tyson fights
when he was fighting holyfield and i
just always loved boxing boxing was was
what i wanted to do um and eventually i
met some guys at a boxing gym who were
doing mixed martial arts they were just
working on their striking and i went to
their gym and the story's history you
know it just snowballed into a career of
fighting
but
that when i was younger and and uh when
i dropped out of school finding combat
sports the thing for me was when i was
watching these guys fight the grit and
determination that they showed i just
for some reason knew i had that whatever
that was i knew i could do that didn't
know if i could fight with the best guys
in the world but i knew i was willing to
suffer more than the next guy and you
knew that idea i knew that i knew that
whatever they had i had
how old were you when you got your first
fist fight first fist fight like a legit
fight
i would probably say 13 years old maybe
do you remember that fight i've had so
many of them i've had so many of them
so 13 years old if somebody was to say
you know everybody has a reputation at
that age some kid was the athlete some
kids the good looking guys some kids the
gangsters some kids the guy that does
baseball cars video games 13 years old
what was your reputation
the guy who did whatever you want you
know i just
did whatever i want or didn't really not
that that's a good thing or boasting
about it i just whatever i felt like
doing i did whether it was um
against the law or against my mother
asking me not to i just kind of did what
i wanted to do
and i still do that these days just
much more focused and doing it the right
way that same energy i had i use it in
the right way now so if you like this
sort of short clip from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]